is there a new offensive in the offering
do you think and could Belarus be
involved
it's very difficult to tell I mean it's
much vaunted meeting between lukashenka
and Putin's been on the cards for a
while we're clearly not aware of what
the objective is clearly um Belarus does
provide a lot of military training for
Russia has also provide lots of military
equipment tanks and equipment to help
support the war
um Putin would love to get Belarus more
intimately involved in this war and
although Putin lukashenko are political
allies the Belarusian people and the
military do not want to get involved in
this war at all so it makes life very
very difficult in terms of why Keith and
why the focus on that well clearly it's
the capital but it's also the center of
gravity for Ukraine in other words a
source of power so inevitably Russia
will be interested in could it could it
take it from military perspective the
Russian border is quite some way away
from Kiev and therefore if you were
going to mount a military attack you'd
want to go up to the north and down
through Belarus which makes it a lot
easier to mount that attack you'd also
need to have a very substantial military
force behind you not only equipment but
also people Russia did Mount 300 000
people it recruiting its mobilization
150 000 of those half them are already
involved in the battle the other 150 000
should be finished their training early
parts of next year so potentially Russia
would have the the troops to do it the
challenge though is that if you remember
back in Spring this year Russia had a
spectacular failure trying to take care
then they will have learned the lessons
from that but so will Ukraine it will be
an extremely difficult nut for Russia to
crack meanwhile the airstrikes are
continuing in Kiev do you think that
will be Russia's policy from now and it
will just continue with the bombardment
throughout the winter well yeah they
have been bombarding across the whole
country but we've seen three attacks on
Kiev in in the last week
um all through drone attacks and it
looks likely Russia's recently taken a
resupply of the Iranian Shahid 136
drones which would explain uh the
attacks the Ukrainian defense systems
claimed they've shot 30 of the 35 down
but some some still get through and even
those they get shot down the pieces tend
to land all over the place this does
seem to be attacking the civilian
population eroding their wheelchair to
to support the war particularly at a
really difficult time of the year and
try to erode support viselensky
partiality is the quite the opposite's
probably occurring in terms of overall
not much fighting movement on the ground
but intense fighting around Bach moot
again we've reported before about the
Wagner group The Mercenary group leading
on that with their use of convicts
um huge casualty rates largely seem to
be driven by tactics of the vasner group
that see the convicts as Expendable one
of those harsh brutalities of War on a
slightly lighter note though Russians
are very concerned about the morale of
their soldiers therefore they are
deploying musical musicians in to try to
entertain the troops it's called a
creative Brigade from my experience the
military particular on operations I
think the um the conscripts will be much
more focused on casualty rates poor
leadership lack of pay lack of
ammunition lack of poor equipment and
the like but just maybe Putin's right
maybe a Christmas carol might help